oh my God
chapstick it's their return no question
where's the Chapstick I don't have it on
me right now yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah you were off brand yeah no question
way off way off brand can you believe it
are your lips dry super dry oh my God
Kraken sandpaper dry
oh
you can't tell oh my god do we need to
call somebody yeah yeah call yeah
security security
on me we're doing this again oh my God
Todd that's what I'm gonna call you now
because that that's right okay the first
question I have to ask you is are we
getting an album Or Nah stop playing
with us I like playing with you no yeah
you're definitely getting an album this
year it's mixed and mastered it's coming
oh it's ready ready almost ready ready
ready
what can you tell me
I really love it I think I'm excited
about it I love it you know what I'm
saying and I think Q-tip did a masterful
job with the production yeah and I think
you know what it sonically what it's
doing is something very new yeah you
know what I'm saying like it's not
chasing nothing I did before and it's
not chasing nothing that you've heard
recently it's it's a new thing I think
it's I think it's right yeah yeah and
then of course the Grammys that was so
cool what was going through your mind
how are you feeling about it because it
was a huge like iconic moment I was
feeling like you know just you know
honestly I want a ChapStick now I was
feeling blessed too I was feeling
blessed to be on the stage with my
heroes to you know have all my heroes
around me it was amazing like dudes I
grew grew up watching and loving and
then to have people that came after me
and to be able to be an integral part of
making that thing come to life yeah it
was amazing along with Quest curating
and and Jesse and all of them to work
with them and put that thing together
was amazing so it was dope yeah shout
out to Jesse
um lastly so NCIS is coming to an end we
got to talk about that of course
who cried the most on set for one and
for two did you take anything I took
everything yeah of course not the
Chapstick I didn't take the chat I
forgot the Chapstick you know what I'm
saying you wasn't there to remind me you
know what I'm saying but but I but yeah
yeah um I'm not gonna tell him who was
crying you know I'm saying I'm not gonna
tell on nobody everybody else was
snitching yeah but yeah that's the
problem
that's the problem you want to go to
jail you want to go home you know what I
mean yeah that's the problem did you
shut it like one Thug tear we got a
little I felt it I felt The Vibes I felt
it but you know I'm we're not going you
know we're not gonna bite pillows you
know I mean we're gonna keep it together
you know we got to keep it together but
that doesn't mean I didn't care okay
that doesn't mean I didn't care like I
definitely care and definitely love the
relationships I formed I feel energy
from all the people around me I just
believe that it's not about what you
lost it's about what you gained you know
what I'm saying so you know when things
end that those are new beginnings so it
it's really about Focus yeah you know
what I mean what are you focused on are
you focused on oh no this is over or you
focused on okay okay what's my next
adventure you feel me because we could
see your character end up on another
NCIS you never know I mean anything's
possible I mean you know never say never
yeah you know I haven't heard that but
you know Never Say Never I mean we're
here at the party I mean yeah yeah I
mean anything's possible am I going to
be your agent again I mean oh you're my
age because last time the one person
yeah yeah yeah it was a one percent
that's true this is true this is true
what has NCIS we're giving you 10. yeah
go ahead go ahead go ahead go ahead you
know what it's been fun thank you E.T
I'm gonna go home
um what has this show meant to you it's
meant it's been I matured a lot
um learned a lot learned humility
you know what I'm saying learn to uh
that your decisions affect the people
around you you know learn to um
be uh kind of con you know just mindful
that
you know their people from all walks of
life involved in this business and you
have to respect them all you know what
I'm saying it's not only about the
glamor jobs in front of the camera or
even right behind the camera there are
other people you know there's craft
service there's props there's armors
there's you know and there's all of
these people and I learn to respect them
more so I gained a newfound respect just
for people working every day trying to
make it you know what I'm saying it was
dope I love that thank you llo we love
your hats where are you getting them
from these are this is from Italy you
know what I'm saying yeah okay A little
Italian low product when you go over
there bring me back like seven eight in
them joints or something can you do that
you always put me to work that's my job
good to see you